the yonko are without a doubt some of
the strongest characters in one piece
like big one and kaido have ruled the
new world together for decades because
of their insanely powerful devil fruits
Whitebeard was considered the world's
strongest man thanks to his absurdly
destructive trema fruit and even
Blackbeard is becoming the number one
threat to Luffy due to his insanely
overpowered Darkness fruit which of
course leaves us with a very interesting
question on the table what would happen
if Luffy ate the yonko's devil fruits
instead and just like with the other
videos we've done in the series we'll be
starting all the way back from when
Luffy was still a kid to see exactly how
he would use the fruit and if the fruit
would actually change his personality at
all and most importantly if each fruit
would still allow him to become pirate
king and you might be surprised to find
out that even though all of the yonko's
devil fruits are insanely powerful on
paper we're gonna find out that Luffy is
actually quite badly suited for some of
them and he may in fact not even make it
past time skip with certain ones plus
most of the yonko are just stupidly
strong on their own without the devil
fruits and would probably have become an
emperor even without their fruits for
example kaido was already a super
powerful giant demon Oni who was taking
out entire countries as a kid and even
as a child big mom took out an entire
Village of giants which we have to be
honest and say that Luffy is nowhere
close to that powerful as a kid so he's
going to have to be creative or his
pirate Journey will end fairly quickly
but first we're gonna begin back in the
bar with shang's back in chapter one now
this was where child Luffy first ate the
devil fruit that Shanks and his crew had
stolen from a world government ship and
so for this scenario let's just imagine
that instead of Luffy's original Fruit
Shanks brought back this fruit insteads
which means of course that when Luffy
takes a massive Chomp the bar instantly
starts to shake and that's because Luffy
has just eaten whitebeard's which allows
the user to create massive vibrations
that can destroy literally entire
Islands in fact we did see Whitebeard
use these powers to create massive
tsunami-like waves Island shattering
earthquakes and even deliver face
crunching punches however while this
fruit is extremely powerful with its raw
destructive potential I actually think
that this fruit is one of the worst
abilities for Luffy to use because I can
just imagine that 10 seconds after
eating this devil fruit he would
probably already have destroyed the
entire bar let's be real which might
actually mean that Shanks might have to
knock him out or something if Luffy
can't actually control his powers
because one thing to keep in mind is
that we don't really know when
Whitebeard actually got this devil fruit
to me personally I think it would make a
lot of sense if he also got it back at
God Valley when he is already an adult
so if that was true then Whitebeard
would have had a much better chance at
controlling these Powers than a young
redless kid like Luffy I mean even
Blackbeard when he first ate the trauma
fruit had very little control and near
really destroyed all of marineford with
it and so I personally wouldn't want to
be anywhere near earthquake Luffy
because who knows when he could just
lose control and break the ground
underneath you plus I even wonder if the
destructive nature of this devil fruit
might make Luffy's personality even more
Reckless than it already is but let's
just say that Shang sticks around a bit
and helps Luffy figure out how to at
least control his new powers a little
bit and then Luffy grows up like normal
living in the jungle with subtle and Ace
however now instead of throwing fairly
harmless rubber punches now his training
involves controlling massive earthquakes
which means that even though he tries
his best to control these abilities
there are gonna be times when kid Luffy
still is gonna cause massive damage on
the entire islands and if you think
about it this could actually lead to
some truly awful situations for example
Luffy might accidentally Crush Ace Sabo
or the bandits that he grew up with he
could also cause so much damage around
him that the rulers of the Goa Kingdom
send soldiers out to capture Luffy or if
it's a really bad I wonder if GARP
forces Luffy into the Marines to stop
him from destroying the entire Island
whatever happens I think all of this
might either make Luffy more hesitant to
use his powers or on the other hand his
personality could change so that he
cares less about the destruction that he
causes in the first place but let's just
say that after 10 years he can actually
control these powers on land and now
he's ready to set out to sea and at this
point he's of course probably a pretty
strong fighter even without using his
powerful devil fruit which is very
important because if he makes a mistake
and accidentally breaks his ship then
say goodbye to earthquake Luffy right
then and there and so even with just his
base strength he still goes through the
East blue without much difficulty but
then the real problems start occurring
when the straw had started facing their
first major challenges and that is of
course in Alabaster because Luffy's
fight against the Sanford user crocodile
was the first time that he was truly
tested in the story and there's
basically no chance at all that goofy
could beat crocodile with just his base
Powers which would mean that he would
have to use his Tremor abilities however
since this is the first time that he's
actually using his powers in a life or
death situation I think it's gonna be
completely reasonable to assume that he
could cause major destruction to the
capital city of alabaster which of
course means that even if he would
defeat crocodile he would probably have
killed tons of civilians in the process
which would make him less of a hero and
more of an extremely wanted villain in
this case this of course will send his
Bounty Sky High but not exactly in a
good way and if this continues on the
islands that he visits then eventually
the Marines would have no other choice
but to send strong Fighters such as an
admiral to put an end to earthquake
Luffy's Pirate's Adventure so uh yeah
realistically looking at this it's not
gonna be all about just having a super
overpowered devil fruit but more
importantly to have the right devil
fruit for the right person also at the
right time which coincidentally is is
why this next devil fruit is actually a
perfect match for Luffy to eat as a kid
because let's head back to chapter one
and now it is this fruit that has caught
Luffy's hungry eyes and with a single
bite all of a sudden the slap of meat
that is on Luffy's plate suddenly starts
talking to a very confused Luffy and the
rest of the red hat Pirates and before
Luffy can shove the talking piece of
meat in his mouth Shanks absolutely
loses his mind that Luffy has just eaten
the soul fruit now as a little refresher
this fruit allows its user to take
pieces of Soul its own of other users
and then actually turn objects plants or
even animals into actual intelligent
creatures in other words that hunk of
meat slapped on Luffy's plate can now
talk and think for itself we've seen big
mom use this fruit to create entire
Islands full of homies such as this
entire Forest full of living trees and
animals even her ship was given a piece
of Soul so that it could sing and be
alive now on an everyday basis big man
would use Souls from other people but
the important part for Luffy here is
that big mom can also use her own soul
to create extra powerful homies as well
like this Cloud sun or her head sword or
she could take Souls from other people
which if she took too much would
actually kill that person and so as you
might imagine this is yet another devil
fruit that's going to take a ton of
practice for Luffy to actually learn how
to use properly however on the other
hand it isn't quite as dangerous to use
as the trauma fruit so he should be able
to spend a lot of time mastering this
devil fruit ability during his years
growing up on the islands really the
only real danger I can see is that Luffy
would have too much fun creating homies
that he uses up all of his own lifespan
but let's just imagine that Shanks
successfully warns Luffy against using
too much of his own soul and maybe Ace
Ensemble will let Luffy take some of
their own soul as well to use for fun I
mean let's be real they would probably
do that and before Luffy leaves the eye
Island he has created three main homies
that he's going to take with him we have
this Cloud that lets him fly around
easily a super powerful homie staff that
Luffy has learned to fight with which
basically makes him little kid Goku at
this point and then of course his new
Straw Hat homie which is mostly just a
friend for him to talk to but if he
really wants he can probably also turn
into a sword now with these three Luffy
sets off on his journey again the East
blue is probably no problem at all since
he's strong enough on his own plus he
can now fly so he could technically just
skip entire Islands however I do think
that he would still get a ship since he
would probably think it's no fun to just
skip every island along the way and with
the help of his Cloud homie defeating
crocodile in Alabaster is actually no
problem as well because the cloud can
simply send rain down on the Sanford
user allowing Luffy to just smack
crocodile with his staff also next on
going to Sky Pia would be way easier
than the first time since the cloud
homie could just expand to carry the
entire Straw Hat crew and the ship up
into the sky and fighting against NL
would be super interesting actually
because I wonder if the clout homie
could absorb all of ennard's lightning
or even the lightning user himself
because he is made out of lightning
either way Luffy would eventually find
some clever way to defeat NL or at least
make it so that his massive Thundercloud
is no longer a threat before anal flies
away to the Moon which brings us to
water 7 and here's so Luffy would
actually easily be able to catch up with
the secret agents who took Robin because
of his Cloud homie's flying abilities
which would allow the straw hats to
defeat them way before ever reaching
Anna's Lobby in the first place I mean
Man flying really seems to be a very op
ability in one piece if you think about
it and that actually means that Luffy's
next challenge is already gonna be
Thriller bar records I mean come on is
this really even a challenge at this
point but it might be cool to see homies
vs Zombies in the story I guess however
then the crew heads to Saba ODI which is
where we get our first massive change in
so Luffy's journey and that's because
with the help of his very reliable Cloud
Luffy and the crew would have a much
easier time actually escaping the Cyborg
pacifistas and Admiral kizaru after
Luffy punched the Celestial Dragon and
this actually means that the entire crew
escapes unharmed although they still
have to leave their ship behind for now
which now brings us to the most
important change in so Luffy's Journey
because it is right at this time that
Ace is about to be executed at
marineford so let's assume that Luffy
and the crew find out about this somehow
and Luffy is dead set on going to save
him at imple down however unlike the
original story where Luffy went through
with his crazy Prison Break idea this
time he has Nami around to knock some
proper sense into him and since they can
just fly around on the cloud they simply
wait until Ace is being transported to
marineford swooped down to the Marine
ship and then just rescue Ace without
even needing to go through the summit
War oh wow that was actually super easy
which also means that Whitebeard doesn't
need to die at Marine Ford and the crew
next meet up with the emperor of the sea
to drop off Ace and come on I'm very
sure that Whitebeard would be super
grateful for the crew saving Ace which
means that he might even teach the straw
hats about hockey and let them train
with his commanders as a thank you which
of course is extra important now since
we're not gonna have the normal two-year
time Skip and I also wonder what other
creative ways Luffy would come up with
to use his fruit during that time maybe
some combo attacks using Brook Soul
Powers as well plus maybe he could even
make Pony glyphs into homies so that
they could tell them more about the
ancient history I mean I'm sure that
Robin would love that but now with the
hockey buff crew ready to enter the new
world it's time to drop a very
controversial take because I do think
that even though things have gone pretty
smoothly so far pretty sure that so
Luffy would be way weaker than the
original at this point because we do
have to remember that big mom was a
monster as a child already she took out
an entire Village of Giants at the age
of five and there is no way that Luffy
could do that as well and when when
fighting big mom doesn't use her devil
fruit all that much except for the
elemental abilities and her giant swords
in other words she's essentially just a
brawler who has insane levels of
strength durability and hockey so what
this means is that so Luffy would
definitely need to train extra hard with
his hockey since he doesn't have the
power boost that came from his original
devil fruit but let's just assume that
he does do this and combined with his
creative views of homies he goes through
the new world without that much trouble
which of course takes us to his
inevitable clashes with big mom and
kaido where it's really hard to say what
would happen because I mean these fights
in the end seem to most often come down
to Advanced hockey abilities but I do
think that Luffy could use his devil
fruit in more creative ways to also help
during the battle and so in the end I do
think that so Luffy would come out on
top just like in the original and
continue to find the one piece however
even though so Luffy was pretty op even
that version of Luffy simply cannot
compare with the god-like powers of Chop
Chop Luffy yeah I'm actually not kidding
because in case you're forgot buggy the
clown is technically a yonko now which
qualifies him for this video and his
chop chop devil fruit powers are so
completely perfect for Luffy that he
might even be able to do an ultra speed
run of the grand line and find the one
piece in less than a year don't believe
me listen to this power lets you
separate your body parts into pieces
which basically makes you immune to
swords you can also fly as long as your
feet stay on the ground so I can just
imagine Luffy finding all sorts of way
more creative ways than buggy to use
this power but I'm now thinking about
how incredible this fruit would truly be
if Luffy could combine it with his
current devil fruit I mean Blackbeard
has to double fruit so I mean just
imagine if it was possible for Luffy and
that means if you combine Rubber and the
chop abilities okay okay this idea of
Luffy eating two devil fruits is really
interesting so let's save that for a
future video and make sure to subscribe
if you want to see how Luffy having two
devil fruits would actually work in the
story but now since we're saving Buggy's
fruit let's instead move on to one of
the biggest and most badass devil fruit
powers in the entire story and so blah
blah we're back in the bar Luffy takes a
bite of this fruit and he immediately
turns spoof into a little red dragon and
starts Spitting Fire everywhere in panic
that's right the this is going to be
Dragon Luffy however there's actually a
lot of confusion around kaido's devil
fruit because it's officially the fish
fruit model cereal which is a famous
blue dragon and since it's actually
based on an old Japanese myth where a
carp goes up a waterfall and then turns
into a dragon we're actually not sure if
you turn into a fish first and then
later on awaken his Dragon abilities or
if it works just like momonoski's
version of the fruit and you just turn
into a dragon right from the start and
so since we don't really know let's just
go with the more exciting option and
assume that Luffy would be a dragon
right away although honestly it would be
hilarious to see Luffy trying to fight
his way to the Grand line as a tiny fish
that can't swim I will say anyways Luffy
can now become a dragon who has the
mind-blowing ability to control elements
such as shooting out giant blast breaths
calling down lightning and sending
razor-sharp gusts off winds which of
course means that by the time that Luffy
sets out at age 17 he is a legend
legendary creature with Incredible
natural Powers however before we start
we need to make a serious disclaimer
because just like big mom kaido also was
an absolute Powerhouse fighter who was
able to join the legendary rocks crew
even before he ever got his legendary
devil fruit which of course means that
his base Powers once again are absurdly
high which if I'm being honest with you
we probably cannot say about 70 year old
Luffy when he first starts his journey
and unlike when Luffy had his clout
homie I do think that this time as a
dragon Luffy would actually fly around
much more and actually skip Islands
that's because as a dragon he is
literally the king of the beasts which
might make Luffy more arrogant and not
bother with some of the smaller islands
like syrup Village however who knows
maybe Zoro would still challenge him to
not use his Dragon form so he might
still get some practice in normal or his
hybrid form and as always the first half
of the grand line would still be a piece
of cake because of the sheer power
difference that Luffy has as a dragon he
can easily bring down rain or use his
fire to defeat crocodile match lightning
powers with ML and if I'm being honest
he would probably wipe the floor with
cp9 before they can even come close to
escaping with Robin however let's assume
that Thriller bark and Saba ODI go as
usual and the crew gets separated Luffy
ends up on Amazon Lily and finds out
about Aces execution and of course he
still wants to go and save Ace and this
is where the story is Gonna Change
dramatically because there is no way
that Dragon Luffy is waiting to sneak on
a marine ship instead he would probably
just fly straight to imple down himself
and just start destroying the entire
place with his blast breaths however
once he actually gets inside the prison
things would be much more difficult you
see since there is way less space inside
the prison he wouldn't be able to use
his big dragon form which at this point
I still think would be his most powerful
since he doesn't know hockey yet and
that means getting down to save Ace
would probably fail just like in the
original storyline and he would still
have to go to Marine forts which I'm
sorry is going to end so so badly for
Dragon Luffy and that's because since
Luffy's Dragon form is so powerful he
probably wouldn't have these same
massive levels of battle experience that
he would need to make a difference
during this epic war that means that he
would likely have to use his big dragon
form to have any sort of effect on this
legendary Battlefield and so with this
big ass Dragon shooting fire lightning
and wind gusts I think that the Admirals
would have no other choice but to team
up and take out Luffy before he destroys
all of marine Forts and yeah maybe you
can say that Whitebeard would try and
help protect him but honestly since he
is just such a ridiculously big Target I
think that Luffy would just take way too
much damage from kizaru's light beams
and the kainu's magma which
unfortunately means that Dragon Luffy
doesn't even make it into the new world
as much as that sucks however not even
Dragon Luffy's out come is as surprising
as what is going to happen next because
back in the bar Luffy jumps down on this
fruit that looks very much like his
original one and a pool of Darkness
instantly sucks all of his friends into
the floor which of course makes Luffy
completely freak out until he somehow
manages to spit everyone back out just
moments later welcome to the story maybe
the coolest Luffy yet Darkness Luffy and
that the real Chase would probably throw
a major fit over Luffy eating this
particular devil fruit but this might
honestly be one of the most interesting
scenarios for an alternate devil fruit
for Luffy because one thing that we
haven't discussed yet is that if Luffy
eats a different devil fruit then
someone else would still have to eat
Luffy's original Fruit and so let's
assume that Shang still has the sun god
fruit and he plans to give it to Ace
then that would mean that Luffy and Ace
would have the darkness and the sun god
fruits which would just be the most
mind-blowing thing in terms of events
and because the darkness fruit belongs
to one of the main villains of the
entire story we actually do know quite a
bit about how it works and its abilities
as far as we know it's a special logia
that allows the user to produce darkness
which kind of acts like a pocket
Dimension that can suck things in and
crush them with Darkness but the most
important ability that Darkness Luffy
will use is the one that allows him to
suck in other devil fruit users and take
away their powers as long as he's
touching them which is just such a
broken ability in a world where most of
the strong Fighters are devil fruit
users and really the only downside is
that Darkness Luffy won't get the normal
logia invincibility since it instead
absorbs all of the damage that he takes
ouch which now of course brings us to
the nature of this particular devil
fruit and honestly I think that it gets
a bad reputation because we only see it
used by blackbeards but there is nothing
particularly that tells us that this
power is naturally evil because I mean
it was originally found by this guy and
I mean can you imagine him turning into
a super villain if he ate that fruit so
that means we can just assume that
Darkness Luffy is automatically evil
Luffy it just means that he has some
pretty amazing Powers if we're being
real however I do think that this
particular devil fruit would be quite
tough for Luffy to use at least At first
I mean I can't really see him crushing
tons of people and buildings with his
Darkness honestly plus absorbing all
damn damage would be particularly
painful for Luffy since he is usually
such a straight up kind of fighter and
even worse Darkness Luffy wouldn't have
his rubber to help deflect some of that
damage so Luffy is going to have to
train up his base strength and defense
quite a bit and he may even use some
sort of weapon like a staff or a club to
help him fight but really his ability to
negate other devil fruits is just such a
broken power that it comes in handy
right away facing buggy just suck him in
and kick him in the balls for the rest
of the East blue he'd have to rely a
little bit more on his own strength but
in the end I think he would reach the
grand line without any major
difficulties honestly and the next few
arcs are gonna be basically target
practice for Darkness Luffy against
crocodile sand he can just take away his
powers and same with Eno who without his
lightning is just like fighting a cat
without its boss Honestly though I do
think Rob Lucci would probably be a way
bigger challenge because he's pretty
strong even without his devil fruit but
I still think that Luffy would come out
on top here however as Darkness Luffy
continues towards the new world there is
one other major difference to the story
because since Blackbeard doesn't have
the darkest food this time around
there's a pretty good chance that he's
still on whitebeard's crew and if teach
hears that Luffy has eaten the darkness
fruit that he was looking for all along
he would probably come after Luffy right
away however I don't think he would be
able to beat Luffy on his own unless
there was some kind of trick involved so
that means Blackbeard is taken out of
the story completely here which if
you're paying attention means that Ace
is never captured and marineford never
happens bam game changed however before
we move into the new world there is one
major dilemma that the crew will have to
face what happens when Luffy meets
Roger's former right hand Rayleigh and
this is honestly a very tough question
because we don't know the full history
of the yummy yummy Nomi one theory is
that the infamous pirate rocks diesel
back actually ate this particular fruit
and if that's the case would Rayleigh
still help Luffy since the straw hat
Captain has eaten rux's old fruit I'm
honestly not too not too sure about this
but hey let's just say that Rayleigh
does help them and even trains them a
little bit with haki before the straw
heads head into the new world and just
like with the early parts of the grand
Line This is Gonna Go incredibly well
for Darkness Luffy since he basically
only fights devil fruit users such as
Caesar though Flamingo katakuri and so
on and so forth of course the real
challenge comes against kaido and big
mom but however with his unique
abilities I do feel like that Luffy
would be able to overcome these two
devil fruit using yonko and continue his
path to actually find the one piece
which is honestly pretty surprising and
not at all what I expected for Darkness
Luffy when I started thinking about this
video however even though Luffy made it
this far with two out of the four yonko
fruits these are actually not even the
most powerful fruits in the story in
fact many of the most insane devil
fruits actually belong to the warlord so
if you want to know how Luffy's story
would go with fruits like Kuma's reality
bending Paul fruit or do flamingo's
insane string Powers you can watch that
video right here thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one recording
this with a cold was a challenge but we
got through it good job
you and me